you know when giannis comes out and says
oh yeah it's over it's a wrap
it's the best starting five ever tayden
sets it up for
zion williamson well isn't that what you
wanted
that's what i want i just wanted to
break it next time
[Applause]
zion zion
[Applause]
[Music]
this curry had an ocean and shoot a deep
three gets into the paint
scoops rebounded by giannis and puts it
down
zion missed the stuff
see shook his head
[Applause]
good look here from steph curry in the
open court you got the joker running the
floor
right now maybe that extra practice day
oh jason tatum
with the stuff fires for free
[Applause]
off the leg of mitchell lost to curry
with the steals
here is lebron for rudy gobert who just
came on
and how about this one the best passers
of all time
in the game bounce utah fans there's
love there between lebron
and the utah fans and shout out to new
york because i know you've been waiting
for randall
obviously that's why he's here
i just like to talk to myself and reason
it out paul
to set up go there beautifully rare mvp
level and zach levine have the acl it
shows you you put in the time and the
hard work and recover
you can get back to your greatness
this may be the smallest lineup we've
ever seen in an all-star game
if you look upon team lebron the tallest
player
here's field putting it
jalen brown a terrific two-way player
having his second straight outstanding
season the lead
for tatum jason and tatum
by tatum
was talking about he was going to come
to the also game i'll be there
physically but not mentally
he's here both look at the extension
right here by lebron
as we've seen in this game
landed on the back of
[Applause]
the lead for zion williamson
[Music]
in the first half red said he doesn't
need to stretch he says
a young 20 just kion now with six points
[Applause]
doncic finds the opening and he puts it
down
okay i'm talking about athleticism he's
got to see well he does
[Music]
comes across
doctor checking if he's three-point lane
and it's tipped home
by jalen brown
[Music]
it's like a in junior high in high
school
come on man you've been worldwide known
since you were like 12.
got us again
[Applause]
third nod as an all-star head coach he's
the sixers first
all-star game head coach since larry
brown
in 2001 you make him lose the ball
he says something to himself it just
throws it up and it's money
you're really angry aren't you he still
hits the three
welcome to opposing coaches now zion
right back he now has eight points
giannis from paul
[Music]
giannis perfect from the field thus far
in this first half
nine of nine and 19 points
his kawhi leonard across the lane his
pass broken up
hardened with the save ends up at the
hands of paul for giannis
just saying listen why didn't he throw
it off the back
here's paul with the
lead pass just not a three-point shoot
paul inbound a 17-2
run
[Applause]
by team lebron we know the threes
but now he's just
[Applause]
right there again
it's a route for team lebron in the
second quarter
and nicole
time running out and the half
i set up for bradley beal
has a long pass from doctors but yada
said he lays it home
they could have knocked it away he was
hanging a little defense here
and irving on the drive and he starts
[Applause]
with the [ __ ] set up by joking
oh
[Applause]
it's a two-point lead for team durant
here's giannis in the open floor to go
bare
and he stuffs